[Music]
will fuller texans receiver announcing
yesterday that earlier this year i saw a
treatment from a medical professional
who prescribed medication that he
believed to be permitted under the nfl
drug policies it turns out my trust in
this professional was misplaced because
this medication was not a permitted
substance under the nfl policy on
performance-enhancing substances my
standard position
in that regard hold on there's another
statement that's also
bradley roby as well
bradley roby as well hey
and let me just sum it up i didn't do
anything wrong i didn't do anything
wrong i didn't intentionally cheat and
yet again the national football league's
ped policy chris is ensnaring in its
gears
individuals otherwise innocent
who just so happened to take a substance
that they didn't know
was a banned substance meaning that the
nfl continues
to catch non-cheaters while the cheaters
are running around scot-free yeah if you
believe anything yeah no i know it it's
hard to believe it and you know my
thoughts on cheaters i'm not very nice
with this stuff i don't have much uh
compassion at all and especially about
two guys who are in a contract year
and one of them has an injury history
i'm sorry hard for me to buy show me the
medical receipt of what you were
prescribed and then i'll believe you
show me that that's the only way
i know but that's i don't want to hear
it
time and again don't trust anyone you
have a number you can call you have
resources available to you through the
nfl players association you have an
agent you have people you don't just say
the doctor says yeah i think it's fine
no what the doctor would say is you
better check
right now
i'm not a member right of this group
that knows what is and what isn't
allowed exactly and players they're all
about their bodies it's just not
believable to think oh hey he prescribed
it no problem i'm just gonna throw it in
my body and not worry about it i have a
hard time believing a player would do
that in the nfl this day and age so yeah
i can't defend them suspensions knocks
them out for the rest of the season and
actually infringes upon their free
agency because they'll be suspended for
the first game of next year with their
new team or with the texans again
i i here's what i want to know
i want to know how forthcoming the
texans were
with the packers or anyone else yeah
when
when there were discussions about
a trade for will fuller because here's
how it works
if you're considering trading for a guy
you have
the power
yes to contact the league and find out
if that guy is facing any potential
available for suspension right and any
well-functioning nfl organization should
be making that call
for any and every player that it's
considering signing or especially
trading for giving up draft assets right
but you know it's it's if you don't ask
they don't tell
and and i just i just can't help but
wonder
whether or not texans interim general
manager used to be either doesn't
understand the rules or
thought all's fair
maybe we can unload this guy before we
lose him for six games i'm just curious
it's just it i just there may be a story
behind the story because why would you
even start down the path of having trade
conversations for a guy that you
think
may be wiped out
for six games if you're the packers
you're not going to have those
conversations the last year of his
contract there should have been no
conversations or the conversation should
have ended with no this isn't about
whether or not we give up a third round
pick or a second round pick or what
we're gonna otherwise give you this is
about whether or not we're gonna get the
guy on the field this year for more than
a week or two so
it just it it invites speculation about
what the texans said what they didn't
say and whether or not the packers were
even aware of this before it all fell
apart and maybe it's something they
would have they would have done their
due diligence after they knew they were
going to make the trade happen and then
it would have fallen apart but either
way this isn't something that just
popped up yesterday this has been around
and we're not that far removed from when
the trade window closed i just think
that that there's a story out there that
maybe will eventually be told i don't
know this is you know there's two types
of journalism in the nfl there's the
stuff that's going to get announced
anyway congratulations on letting us
know five minutes early and then there's
the stuff that they never wanted anyone
to know that's where the meat is chris
and uh there may be there may be a
little sliver of hamburger flying around
on this one yeah i i wouldn't be
surprised there i i mean really in my
heart of hearts you know when i first
saw this and all the news about will
fuller i right away went well there's
why it never got real real serious with
green bay and will fuller i just thought
hey green bay is pretty smart
organization
i i think they probably got close and
made that call to the league like you're
talking about it's not on the houston
texans to tell them and go hey you know
that's that's not their job hey we're
offering a guy to trade it's you know i
know it's not business nobody's ethics i
know it's it's that that's my that's but
that's why i'm i'm intrigued by it what
did the texans decide to do did they
decide to just keep their mouths shut
and hope the packers were going to screw
up because even if it's fair and
appropriate something like that leaves a
mark if you pull that off
if you if you dump a guy onto a team
that's unsuspecting and doesn't make the
phone call and you get a second round
pick or whatever yes it's all's fair but
you know it's a relationship driven
business and that would have i think
been a real problem for people in
houston not just with the packers but
with other teams if they had pulled
something like that i'm just i'm just
curious how far did it get what did the
packers know did they make the phone
call would they have made the phone call
some of these things we'll never know
but uh it it i just think the fact that
a guy one of the only guys
with significant name recognition and
and they created some fascination whose
name was on the trade market ends up
being a guy who gets popped for six
weeks to end the season it just invites
further research
and and journalism other than just
waiting for a text from a coach or a gm
five minutes before they announce that
they're going to cut someone or sign
someone or something like that which is
98 percent of the journalism that we see
in professional sports
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports